في 14 مارس سنه 2021 قام من النوم اكثر من
7 مليون شخص اجنبي على تنفيذ مبادره تحسين
العلاقه التعاقديه بين العامل وصاحب
العامل
الغاء الكفيل حيز التنفيذ في السعوديه
اللي بتحسن اوضاع العمال الاجانب في
السعوديه بعدها بدات الاخبار تستخدم مصطلح
الكفاله
وكان محطه انتقادا من منظمات حقوق الانسان
وحقوق العمال لانه يجرد العامل من بعض
حقوقه هذا بيخلينا نحتاج نفهم وش يعني
كفاله اصلا كيف ومتى بدات وهل مبادره
تحسين العلاقه التعاقديه تنهي موضوع
الكفاله فعلا
[موسيقى]
حتى نفهم اللي صاير الحين نحتاج نرجع 100
سنوات وتحديدا في البحرين واللي وقتها
كانت تحت نفوذ الاستعمار البريطاني وكانت
كذلك تعتمد على تجاره اللؤلؤ كمصدر الرئيس
الاقتصادها اثناء موسم اللولو الاشخاص من
شرق السعوديه وغيرها من دول الخليج يروحون
مع الغواصين البحرينيين في رحلات البحث عن
لولو هذا التزامن مع ظهور الحدود الجديده
بين دول الخليج وكذلك مع شرطه التنقل
الجديد
[موسيقى]
حتى يسيطر على حركه الاجانب الموجودين في
السفن البحرينيه الحل هذا النظام الكفاله
اول تشكل للمنظومه الكامله للنظام الفصاله
ظهرت في اواخر العشرينات في البحرين عندما
كان بريطانيه في قوه العمل التي تاتي وقت
الغوص طبعا كانت تحصل من مئات السنين لكن
الان بلاوي يصنفون من ياتي كاجانب الى
البحرين اللي ياتون من مثلا من ال من اي
مكان اخر في الخليج
يسولفونك اجانب ويرتبطون تواجدهم بقبطان
السفينه او انه ناخذها لفعليا كان كفيله
وقت استقلال الدول الخليجيه من نفوذ
الاستعمار البريطاني والتزامن كذلك مع
طفره النفط في الستينات والسبعينات اخذت
هذه الدول القوانين الموضعه نصفقا من
بريطانيا طبقتها على العمال الوافدين
عندهم هذه النظام تعمم في باقي الدول ومن
ضمنها السعوديه وما ارتفاع ارادات النفط
في دول الخليج صارت الوظائف الحكوميه اكثر
جذبه للمواطنين هذا زاد الحاجه للعمال
الاجانب عشان يشتغلون في المنشاهات الخاصه
النفطيه فهمم من بدا عندنا نظام الاستقدام
التعاقد لكن تم التعامل مع الوافدين
بطريقه يمكن تراعي طبيعه المجتمع فالعام
البلد المسؤول عنه اللي يسمى الكفيل وصاحب
العمل كلمه الكفاله في اللغه ترجع للجذر
كفله واللي ياخذ معاني كثير
منها هائل اي الكفيل هو الوصيه القانوني
للمفعول به المكفول او يضمنه ويصبح
المسؤول عنه هو المسؤول عن مراجعه الجهات
الحكوميه نيابه عنه ما يدخل جهه حكوميه ما
يستخرج رخصه الا موافقه صاحب العمل ما
يمتلك سياره ما يفتح حساب بنكي سكن ايضا
ساجر لازم موافقه صاحب العمل هذا فضلا عن
موضوع الخروج النهائي وهو يغادر البلد ولا
يطلع خروج مؤقت ولا يرغ في انتقال اخرى
هذه كلها ما تتم الا موافقهم العمل
[موسيقى]
البريطاني وفي التشابه يعني في ايضا
اعتماديه على عماله اجنبيه مهاجره مع دول
الخليط طبعا مع نسبه لا يوجد دول في
العالم همم يعني مثلا تصل الى هديه
الاعتماديه على عماله همم مهاجره اجنبيه
والخليج تصل الى يعني 95% مثلا من قوه
العمل في قطر وفي الامارات ااا مهم يعني
من غير المواطنين وفي كل دول الخليج طبعا
اللي ما فيها السعوديه نسبه غير المواطنين
من قوات العمل هي اكثر من النصف المشكله
الاساسيه في نظام الكفاله بالخليج انه
وجود العام الاجنبي في الدوله مرتبط في
انسان بشكل مباشر هو الكفيل فممكن تتعطل
حياتها بحسب مزاج ورغبه هذا الكفيل العكس
نماذج مختلفه في باقي دول العالم واللي
تربط العامل المؤسسه مباشره في سر موظف
تعاملاتك كلها تخضع لقوانين الدوله مع
مؤسسه على طول وبعد عقود من تطبيق نظام
الكفاله على العمال الاجانب في دول الخليج
بدات تظهر مشكلات قانونيه واقتصاديه
مرتبطه وفي بعض الاشياء تذهب للمواطنين
وللعمال الوافده يعني مثلا دعم المياه دعم
الكهرباء همم دعم الغذاء كان مثلا الخبز
او غيره كل هذه الدعومات كانت تذهب
للمواطنين ولل
للعماله الوافده حتى كان في تقديرات ان
مثلا في البحرين في فتره معينه ان كل عام
الوافد يعني تكلفه حوالي من ناحيه
الدعومات حوالي 70 دينار او 700 ريال اييه
شهريا في فتره من الفترات يعني على الدوله
وايضا يعني كان في تكلفه من ناحيه الاموال
التي تخرج من التحويلات الى الخارج
مع نموذج عليك الدعم التي تقدمها الدوله
للمواطنين والعماله الوافده مثل ما قال
لنا في بعض الامور وايضا زادت الاموال
التي تحول للخارج فهذه جانب واحد صار فيه
همم يعني تكلفه بنات الدوله لازم تفكر فيه
حسب بيانات اصدارها البنك المركزي السعودي
في سنه 2021 نلقى بالنا تحويلات اجانب
المقيمين في السعوديه تعادل 41 مليار
دولار تقريبا هذه بعض المشكلات دقيقه لكن
مشكلات القانونيه فهي تتعلق حريه العامل
متنقل بين الاعمال المختلفه خروجه ورجعته
من والى الدوله اللي يشتغل فيها ويقول هنا
مشكلات قانونيه لان ما كان في نظام واضح
العمال الاجانب وفي تغيرات في دول الخليج
على هذه الاجزاء من هذه النواحي وطبعا
يعني في في كثير منها كانت يعني تغيرات
يعني فيها تغير ملم
وسه لكن دول الخليج استعملت هذه التغيرات
بعضها للقول ان احنا ننهيين النظام
الكفاله لكن في جوهره في جوهره اذا بنقول
ان النظام الكفاله وهو يحدد العلاقه بين
ال همم العمال الوافده والاجنبيه في دول
الخليج تواجدها في دول الخليج ويربطها
بتواجد كثير يحتاج قوه عملهم وفي النهايه
في النهايه يعني عليهم الخروج مع انتهاء
همم
طلب الكثير عليهم هذا العزاء موجود في
2009 كانت البحرين هي اول مبادرين من دول
الخليج في الغاء نظام الكفاء بعد ما اصدرت
نظام بديل تحت مسمى تصريح العمل المرء هذا
النظام يتيح للوافد حريه الاقامه في
البحرين والعمل في اي وظيفه غير تخصصيه
بدون كفيل لمده سنه او سنه سنتين في العام
نفسه بدات الكويت هو الخطوات الغاء نظام
الكفيل في قرار يخص مرجعيه العامل الاجنبي
المقفول بنفس القرار على
اه موافقه الكفيل على تحويل اقامه العامل
لكفيل اخر من دون اذن الكفيل الاول بعد
قضاء العام لفتره لا تقل ثلاثه سنوات لدي
الكفيل اللي يعمل لديك وبعدها بسنه اعلنت
الامارات عن بدء الغاءها نظام نقل الكفاله
واللي كان يحضر على العامل في القطاع
الخاص الانتقال من شركه ثانيه بدون ما
ياخذ موافقه صاحب العمل الاصلي هذا هو
الوضع في بعض دول الخليج لكن ماذا عن
السعوديه الاجراءات السابقه في همم
التعامل مع الوافدين والعلاقات التعاقديه
اللي كانت تخرج عن طائر العلاقه التعاقديه
او العقد بين العامل وصاحب العمل اللي همم
كانت تتركز خصوصا في موضوع فقط
ايا كان الوضع العقد وكذلك اشتراك موافقه
صاحب العمل على الخروج
اللي بلده وامه خروج مؤقته خروج نهائي
كلها اثار متعدده وصور ساهمت في تشويه
سوق العمل بصور متعدده هذه المشكلات بدي
احلها من زمان وتحديدا من عام 2000 ميلاد
اللي يوافق 1421 هجري بصدور قرار مجلس
الوزراء رقم 166 ينص على عدم استخدام
مصلحه كفاله
الحكوميه لاي مصالح لها او الافراد اسرته
دون اشتراط موافقه صاحب العمل ايضا تنقل
وافد داخل المملكه
كفاله لا وجود لها قانونيه انما
استخداماتها هي ترخصبات مجتمعيه للفكر
الخاطئه اساسا سواء استخداماتها في السياق
الاجتماعي او حتى في بعض الجهاز الرسمي
لكن هل كذا انتهت المشكله لا فما زال
العامل الاجنبي في السعوديه ما يقدر ينتقل
بين عمله وعمل اخر الا موافقه صاحب العمل
اساسي وكذلك عنده قيود في مواضيع الخروج
والعوده او حتى الخروج النهائي هذه الامور
اللي اشتغلت على حلها مبادره تحسين
العلاقه التعاقديه بين العامل وصاحب العمل
في السعوديه
[موسيقى]
مبادره على ثلاث تحسينات
حريه نقل وظيفي وخدمه الخروج والعوده كذلك
خدمه الخروج النهائي الوضع السابق لا يمكن
للعام الوافد تغيير صاحب العمل يعني ينتقل
من المنشا اللي هو يشتغل عندها اليوم الى
موجه اخرى الا بموافقه صاحب العمل ايا كان
الحال سواء عنده عقد او ما عنده عقد او
انت عقد او صاحب العمل ماذا فعل الاجور او
همم لاي حاله كانت الامر بيد صاحب العمل
هو صاحب الموافقه جديد هو ان ان تم تعديل
هذه العلاقه واصبحت مرتبطه بعقد العمل فك
صاحب العمل انت اليوم مرتبط اي علاقه خالص
ترى هذا العقد همم تحكموا انظمه الدوله
ولا يحكمها ولا تتراك همم لصلاحيات صعبه
اما عن الخروج والعوده والخروج نهائي في
الفرق صار فان العامل يقدر نفسه يصدر
تاشيره الخروج والعوده والخروج النهائي
التابعينا عكس اللي كان موجود قبل واللي
يحصل الخدمه هذه صاحب العمل لان هو اللي
عنده صلاحيه ستار تاشيرات العامل وما زال
خروج العامل وعوده او حتى خروج النهائي
بقرار من صاحب العمل فما نقدر نقول اننا
نهين النظام الكفاله كليا ولكن هذا شكل
العلاقه التعاقديه بين العامل وصاحب العمل
حاليا
[موسيقى]